[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour we've had a little bit of
hiatus but
excited to jump into these conversations
again and today we're going to be
talking about
race politics religion and mental health
in america
so some heavy topics but some important
topics and really excited for two guests
i have on the program today
the first that i'd like to introduce i'm
honored to be able to welcome professor
eddie cloud jr to the addie hour
as many of you probably already know dr
glaude is one of the nation's most
prominent scholars
he's an author a political commentator a
public intellectual
and a passionate educator who examines
the complex dynamics of the american
experience
dr glaude is the james s mcdonald
distinguished university professor and
chair of the department of african
american studies at princeton
he's a morehouse graduate who also holds
a master's degree
in african-american studies from temple
and a phd
in religion from princeton dr glad is
someone who is a columnist for time
magazine he's also a regular contributor
on programs like morning joe
deadline white house with nicole wallace
and meet the press
and he's someone who continually
challenges us to examine our collective
american
conscience and in his words to not to
posit the greatness of america
but to establish the ground upon which
to imagine the country anew
so i'm honored and thrilled to be able
to welcome professor glaude to the addie
hour this morning thanks for being here
it's my pleasure looking forward to it
looking forward to it as well
my next guest i'd like to introduce is
none other than a.d
lumkile thomason who is a speaker poet
and award-winning filmmaker he's spoken
around the united states and
in places like sudan south africa china
and palestine
and he's also the author of permission
to be black my journey with jay-z
and jesus where he acknowledges and
confronts the reality of racial trauma
and shares his story to give permission
to readers to be black
to be christian and to be the person god
has made them to be
a.d is a native of detroit he has more
than 17 years of experience
preaching and teaching the peace of
jesus and ethnically divided countries
cultures and communities and so i'm
honored to be able to welcome a.d to the
podcast today thanks for being here
it's good to be here excited i know we
were joking offline too i didn't get the
memo about the uh the coordination with
the shirts i'm still feeling a little
bit left out but i think hopefully you
know
as we roll with this conversation i'll
feel i'll feel a sense of belonging and
including
um just you know just to start out you
know the topics obviously we're going to
be talking about are heavy and these are
topics that you all talk about on a
regular basis and i really appreciate
the way both of you are
uh public scholars and have really
helped us to continue to think about
our history as a nation are present and
our future
but one of the things i just want to do
to start out the listeners know that we
often just like to check in and see how
people are doing
but i'm curious to know what the topics
that you all engage in how do you
continue to engage in those topics
while also taking time to kind of watch
your own emotional wellness
balance your your time management work
life balance all those things how how do
you how do you do that on a day-to-day
basis
uh dr glover we could start out with you
it's a challenge you know because
i find myself um having to
comment almost every day on the state of
the country you know
uh you know i'm being asked to interpret
the drums as adolf reed would say
um and so you know in my in my work i
talk about finding your elsewhere
a place that allows you to get the
requisite distance
from the reality of the world and so you
know you got to have those people who
love you unconditionally so i just
i just flew down to memphis and hung out
with my boys that i've been i've known
since since my morehouse days we all
just met there and just had an
extraordinary time
um you know i i disappear into novels
i'm finishing
i just finished a wonderful novel by
anna anna burns entitled milkman and
then i reread the parable of the soar by
october butler
and now i'm finishing up sugar bane
sugary bane by
douglas stewart so you know just kind of
disappear into fiction
in some ways uh so you know finding
finding a respite um
in friends and in in in novels that's
been the way my i've been keeping my
head on my shoulder
that's great and it sounds so
intentional too i mean even the time
that you spend
reading books hanging out with folks i
imagine you know that takes time too so
i'm impressed that you're
you carve out the time for that do you
ever get any pushback in terms of
you know why are you not available for
this and that or i mean how have you
navigated that yeah i mean you know
everybody you know once you
once you acquire a certain kind of
public standing that you know everybody
thinks that they
that everyone's asking for your time and
so you just have to be uh very
deliberate about being able
being able to carve out your own time
and being able to cultivate the capacity
to say no
and i needed a you know because i'm the
chair of a department um
you know i'm i'm public you know i'm
traveling around the country i'm doing
television i'm writing
i just needed you know you got to
replenish because this is not a sprint
this is a long distance race so you got
to be able to
to at least carve out some time for
yourself so some people might
be annoyed when i say no but which we
know we try to say it in a generous way
like i was
like i got home training you know yeah
yeah but i think that's so important i
think that's encouraging for others to
hear
too because i think sometimes people
look at folks like you and they're like
how do they do that how do they bounce
at all how they keep going so to be able
to hear
kind of that behind the scenes and know
there are times that you're you're
saying no and really
focusing on what you need to do to stay
in that place i think is really
important
absolutely doc a.d what about you
yeah i mean it's i'll make it i'll
simplify it and just say i try to
connect with uh
nature and silence uh to me silence
rejuvenates me you know so some tangible
things i
i'll do i'll go fishing and turn the
phone off
you know and i could be out there from
sun up to sundown
just in my thoughts um 12 hours a day
i got a bow so i do bow hunting and i'm
out there doing archery
and in the woods and target and
and uh it's good um you know i do read
i like film you know like that fiction
that can remind me of
the possibility of what could be despite
what
is you know so aspirational things
and yeah you got to connect with people
who have a like mind but they don't want
anything from you i think that's the
rare
reality is finding people who don't want
anything or won't turn the conversation
in their favor but they just like your
presence so that those are probably the
the things that i would do
yeah i do that that's definitely good is
that something that you've done from the
get-go or were these things that you'd
say you developed over time
uh necessity definitely over time out of
necessity
um you know you look at different
characters
in in the history from um
[Music]
you know you take the dalai lama going
on in creation
or gandhi king
you know christ himself you just see
there's something with creation in
silence
you know um in in
like uh you know or said earlier like
you know people will steal that time if
you let them so you have to have a
discipline
a muscle of saying no in a kind way to
replenish yourself
yeah yeah i think that's so good i
wanted to bring it home to students a
little bit too because you know just in
my experience working with students i
mean i'm always
encouraged by their passion and how
willing they are to jump into so many
important topics and conversations and
and
fights to be honest um in a lot of ways
and i see that really with the you know
the generation coming up but then at the
same time sometimes like you all were
both talking about
i don't always see the willingness to
say no and so people get themselves
spread really thin
and especially with the emotional toll
that comes with it not always having
time to kind of step back
and take care of themselves or if mental
health challenges come up
really not having the tools to address
those types of things
i'm curious not even just in terms of
timing but in terms of topics how do you
all
decide what topics to engage in and when
to pull back and say okay
you know i'm passionate about this but
this is something that right now i just
need to make sure i don't
spread myself too thin and just go a
thousand miles an hour or
like pick which battles to to engage in
pressure glad you want you know i you
know you
the temptation in this world
particularly in the world of punditry is
that you
you you can speak on everything
you know and you know they're you know
it is point about silence is really
really key
right sometimes you just have to you
know understand that
this is not your lane you know i could
talk about this i have i have
opinions on it but this is really not
where my expertise
lies so why am i talking right
um and so a lot of times i find myself
you know making uh decisions
right based upon you know somebody else
could be
somebody else might be better here why
why do i need to occupy this space
right open it up for someone else let
someone else step in there
uh so you know you i make i make
decisions on the one hand
you know around you know what i know
what's my value add to the conversation
how might i frame it differently uh on
the other hand
and then there's there's another you
know what i'm not a guy who
wants to talk about you know popular
culture a lot
right so you know i'm not the one you're
gonna call to talk about jay-z
or dmx or you know or cardi b
that's not that's not my zone right so
you again
knowing where you are right so so what
does it mean
when i'm being asked to reflect on a
movie or a film or
or a popular cultural event
understanding where i am and trying to
be consistent with who i
am right so i think part of it has
everything to do both of those points
have everything to do with being
consistent
being trying to be consistently clear
about the about the purpose of your
voice
and why you're speaking what is your
platform
for how does it relate to your calling
and when you when you when you ask
yourself those questions then you're not
pursuing
opportunities in order to cultivate
brand
that's good you see you just because
you're doing something that has more
that is more than just simply you run in
your mouth
so so that becomes the basis of making
of making these sorts of choices because
if not
somebody i ask you to talk about any if
anything anything and everything and
you know you know you know it's this you
know something happens to black people
what do you think black people think
right so because you're the interpreter
of black folk you know so you got to be
very very very deliberate in this in
this regard
yeah i think that's so good from the
standpoint of speaker a little bit
curious because how do we
i'm curious what you think about how
people should filter that as consumers
in a sense because as a speaker you have
control about whether you step into a
conversation or not
grand there are a lot of people who are
stepping out of their lane and still
speaking into conversations
so from the receiving end like how do we
how do we filter that and just not get
taken up by everything that everyone has
said about every single topic
well you know this is this is one of the
challenges i'll just say this really
quickly then i'll shut up right one of
the challenges about our current moment
is that there's a kind of leveling
that happens right the kind of
disappearance of expertise and so
because of social media platforms and
the light everybody can be an expert on
anything
and everything and so you have to be a
kind of discerning listener
right how do you how do you absorb
information how do you
who do you extend authority to right
what
material are you drawing on in order to
form your opinion so
um i think part of what we have to do in
this moment
where seriousness is under attack is
cultivate the habits of listening
intelligently
right cultivate the habits of uh
acquiring um a kind of ruthless
uh orientation
to what you take in because as we're
taking in all this information man we're
also taking in a lot of toxins
yeah i mean i mean you on twitter for
just
15 minutes you just kind of like damn i
need to go brush my
i need to go take a bath or something
because it's just a lot of negativity
just kind of coming at you over and over
and over again
so the the implication of that leveling
is that you know everybody thinks they
know everything when
hardly anybody's reading these days or
they're reading at the surface so you
have to become a much more discerning
listener yeah
and choose who you're going to lend
authority to yeah as opposed to just
accepting everybody's voice
yeah you know that's true yeah a.d
before we swing back just to your field
trip
i'm just curious you know also in your
role as a professor because some of the
topics that you teach about
you know about human rights decolonizing
your faith filmmaking and things like
that
are there ways that you guide your
students through that filtering process
because those topics too i'm assuming
that you're deconstructing a lot of
presuppositions as you get into that so
i feel like a lot of these topics would
likely come up in the classroom for you
yeah i mean that's a
that's a good way to say it
deconstructing people's presuppositions
man that is that is that is a hard task
because because when people have
presupposed
and concluded they'll see
that in anything even if it's not there
um so i i think people have one app of
fear missing out
you know and because they have such a
fear missing out they'll take in
the toxic and the healthy
but the problem is they don't know how
to distinguish between two anymore
you know so now people are becoming
experts just
on being up on the trash
that's a new thing whereas before in our
generation
we actually wanted to go to the expert
because they put
in the time not because they were
charismatic or right et cetera et cetera
so
kind of lost that so what i challenge my
students on
is having a grind a work ethic to dig
you know and a lot of people just don't
want to dig they they want to
they have a fear missing out and then
they don't want to dig when you got
social media it
it gives you the best of all that when
you're lazy
you don't want to miss out you're like i
just take in whatever comes my
way right and we know that that doesn't
make a
i would call an honest intellectual
uh an honest pundit right it just makes
one who becomes now personalities
and so that that's why i challenged them
i said are you going to be a person or a
personality
yeah yeah like that yeah
that's good how do students react with
that it's
i mean it's refreshing for them actually
you know
because no one no one is challenging
them on that you know
i think you know what eddie said earlier
is good who you give authority to
it's almost like why why
do you give your authority away so
easily
they whatnot tell me what tell me what
they did oh
they they got a 10 time platinum record
so that's why you follow what they say
on civil rights hmm
no yeah
obviously being facetious but that's
what uh you got to show them their
broken philosophy sometimes yeah
yeah that's really good to push on that
a little bit though i mean i'm thinking
of the flip side of that too what do you
think about you know the situations
where people are kind of sharing from
their lived experience you know you know
thinking back to lebron and the uh just
shut up and dribble type of comment
how do we balance those two sides of it
i think you're right at one hand
if someone's platin selling artists
doesn't mean that they have put in the
grind
on certain components but at the same
time we have the flip side where people
are just invalidating
people speaking into these social issues
when they should i mean how
do you what do you all think about that
line how do we how do we balance that
all right let me give let me give a a
dwayne wade live to
eddie on this one so i i'm not a
proponent of shut up and dribble in its
connotation
but i am when you haven't done the work
and i'm gonna tell you why
because what happens is they'll give
authority
to a lebron who hasn't read anything
and then millions of people start
walking it out like yeah man
see what we gotta do is we just gotta
say after police man
you know not that lebron said that but
when people start talking and they
haven't done the actual work
then you're swaying culture in a way
with that lack of work ethic
so you know just to pick up that because
i'm going to take it and do this with it
um there is a you know
there are examples of courage
that abound in everyday life and people
who have a lot to lose
when they exhibit that courage is worth
lifting up
so when someone says shut up and dribble
and you
and you respond that is that is a moment
right where you know lebron james
thought more
about himself as a man
as a human being than himself as a kind
of product as
a basketball player that's that's but
but it doesn't follow from that
right that now lebron or jay-z for that
matter can step into
you know the the brouhaha over
for example the the national anthem in
the foot in the nfl
and suddenly because you are a
businessman and you have this
cachet that you can enter into that
space and suddenly resolve
everything that colin kaepernick was
trying to do and the folk around him
were trying to do
right so i think it's really important
just to pick up on 80's point right
that examples of courage
right are important um but
they come it also comes with when we
talk about
moving from a moment to a movement it
also requires
right a kind of depth of learning so so
you know and and people are influential
in a number of different areas whether
they're in sport whether they're in
acting whether they're in the business
world um
whether there's your there's your uncle
or your aunt folks are influential
but it doesn't necessarily just because
they're influential in one moment
doesn't mean that they're influential in
all moments
see that's good you
catch that
did you catch that and i'm a again i'm
gonna do another move i'll pass it back
in here here's what i think people miss
and what
he's saying we don't
pass the ball to the right person
anymore we assume we're supposed to take
the shot
right you see what i'm saying so if if i
know eddie has put in his work and they
ask him
something on politics i go yeah i can
give insightful but i go nah
i'ma pass it to him and we don't see
people
in those platforms have the right
relationships to pass to the right
person
or at least be mentored by the right
person that they should be passing to
right so so my question were like why
why is it a lebron
being mentored by the eddie gallaudets
in the world so when they ask him that
question he's like bam i know what to
right well you know i i would i would
hope that he has some folks in his camp
i pray that he does but you know i think
i think it's really i think that's a
really important point it goes back to
something i said earlier a.d
um and that that you know
the temptation is to hog the mic
it is that you that you know you think
you can just because you got it
you're supposed to speak on everything
and
the discipline the spiritual discipline
actually
to actually be quiet and pass the mic
it's something that we have to cultivate
that's good you know
yeah i like them wow
that's so true i think the challenges
actually
cultivating getting to that point
helping people cultivate that
i mean i think it's it's uh it's
refreshing to hear both of you
espouse that here i'm just i guess i'm
trying to how does that
work out practically let me give you an
example let me give you a crack
practical example
bob moses god bless his soul
you know i wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for
what bob moses did in mississippi you
know i'm a country boy from moss point
mississippi
snick was in moss point um hollis
watkins i mean stokely carmichael all
these folk
um and miss ella baker told the snick
folk
you know shut up and listen maybe you
might learn something
as they were organizing share crops
and so bob's orientation was to enter
into spaces
and create the conditions under which
indigenous leadership would emerge
because he was saying we are the leaders
we've been looking for
and so at the heart of his politics is
the politics of tending
tending to the person right in front of
you tending to the situation
right in front of you which means you
have to have the habits of listening you
have to be perceptive you have to be
empathetic
all of these things so at the heart of
snip
as a civil rights organization
right is moving into spaces that people
thought
we're at the margins of american
democratic life
right and creating the conditions under
which a fannie lou hamer could emerge
come on you see what i mean so so part
of what we have to do
oftentimes in in this culture this
moment now
we're so preoccupied with our own
individual brands we're so preoccupied
with projecting
or as we would say getting something on
consignment so we can then get our
hustle
come on i'm going to i'm going a little
too deep
give me give me this so then i can do
this and you know
so because we all want to get in the
game yeah yeah right
not understanding what really what we're
trying to do really is change the game
entirely
and that's going to require not folk
getting out front
necessarily but all of us kind of
creating the conditions under which
each and every other person can become
the fullest human being that they're
called to be
if that makes sense no sure so to answer
your question directly because
right he wants he wants some tangibles i
guess
i could see the neural signs in his
brain he's like man i need some 10 steps
can't hide it you you know i i think
we've been fortunate to know our story
to look at our story what are some
resonating themes so i
if if i would say something to people i
say write out your story where did you
grow up
mom dad what's their story siblings no
siblings
the environment if you fortunate college
you know masters doctorate write out and
you'll start to see
things and going back to uh eddie's
point earlier
when you see those themes you will know
what you're supposed to be saying yes to
and the problem is people don't know the
theme of their life so for me
my theme is storytelling
integrity and fighting for those who are
oppressed
those are my themes so i know what to
say yes to and i know what to say no to
i know what to pass
past to even if someone gives me the
opportunity i'm gonna pass
right and recommend someone else i think
a lot of people don't know
themselves and i would even say this
a lot of people may know themselves they
want to be something else
because of the glory that may come with
it so now you're talking about humility
you see what i'm saying everybody you
know it's funny when people read like
things on
mlk or things on like the gandhis or the
you know even christ itself they always
read themselves as
mlk gandhi they never read themselves as
the secondary third or the person on the
side of the road but but a lot of us may
be
the onlooker who's trying to get the
courage to be that person
and that's okay it's okay if you're the
tiller
and the one who plants the seed and
never brings in the harvest but your
work matters
you know that's good i mean two themes
i'm hearing coming out from both of you
just
community and purpose so you know yeah
you're talking about just
tending to the people and the building
the community and here comes the
neuroscience data
you pulled it out but just the
importance of that for our brains
in general and what that does are when
people talk a lot about oxytocin and
other things that we have when we're in
community
and social interactions with others and
how that helps us get to a place of
peace
and how it makes us more effective in
what we do on a day-to-day basis and 80
as you're bringing out just all the
aspects of purpose
and how that guides what you say yes to
what you say no to i mean i think those
those pieces both of those are really
important and critical
guiding pieces for people moving forward
and you know you know with the theme of
the pack has to all those tie into
mental health
so all the pieces that you're bringing
up if those are lost that's when people
start to to get afraid in a sense
because everything we're talking about i
mean all these people they're
they're emotionally heavy they're taxing
i mean you've written about the racial
trauma and you've talked about that
quite a bit as well
and we don't have that community and
that purpose i think it's that much
easier
for those challenges to emerge and then
to people again to lose track of really
being centered
and having that place and those tools
because you know i mean this is it
sounds like a cliche but
when people spread themselves too thin
and don't attend to themselves and they
can't help anybody else
if they're not in a place of wholeness
themselves and that's not to say that we
have to be completely whole too
engaged but we can't ignore it obviously
and think that we're going to be
effective in other people's lives yeah
that's good yeah you know i um you know
i
we you know i have this view that you
know
all of us inevitably will lose our way
it's just what it means to be human you
know that's good the temptations will be
what they are
and you know the thing is that you know
passing the mic is hard when people are
giving it to you
over and over and over again trying to
anoint you trying to make you the
spokesperson make you
the you know always that article the not
a
but the right um and so when you lose
your way
because you will the question is what do
you have
to recalibrate to re-center i like that
and so i'm a mama's child i'm juanita
glaude's child juanita had her first
baby in the ninth grade
she was cleaning toilets for a living
then became a supervisor of
of the janitorial crew at the ingles
shipyard bill
right so whenever i lose my way i have
something to re-center to recalibrate
who am i in relation to that
representative that representation of
value
is at the core of who i am so when
people don't have the ability to
recalibrate
that's when they become dangerous
so i think i think this because you know
i i'm skeptical of wholeness
that's good you know i'm skip you know i
i use the analogy of katsugi uh pottery
you know
that japanese pottery where you know you
can have a crack
it's a crack piece of pottery right but
they fill it with gold
the crack doesn't disappear so the
crackpot
is actually more valuable than the
original version
so i don't like to aspire for wholeness
i'm i'm i want to find
beauty in my brokenness because you see
it
does that make sense i'm speaking to the
neuroscientists
you're good you're good all right all
right ada you see i'm gonna back up off
that one i'm gonna leave it alone cause
he's like
let me let me break this down you're
good i mean
everything that comes from from the pain
too exactly
of moving forward because now we always
talk about that with broken bones but
there are ways that that happens
with our brains too i mean they're all
the the processes and developmental
processes we go through
and you know people like to throw around
the word plasticity but just the changes
that can happen our brains when we go
through certain surfaces some of that
plasticity can happen
through painful circumstances right and
it's it's an ongoing process it happens
with the good things that happens with
the bad things that all gets us to the
place
where we are now so it's not to say that
we avoid
the pain and i mean if we're thinking in
terms of psychology that's kind of that
cliche of
avoid avoidance so if you have to deal
with something you need to deal with it
and move through it if you avoid it it's
just going to fester
and so you have to i mean there's a pain
that comes with that there's brokenness
that comes with that but we get to a
stronger place of healing on the other
side we learn those skills so i'll give
you that uh that neuroscience validation
for you
i like that
hey what are you gonna are you gonna
respond there too before i
just do this no no no just double click
and say that
you know that personality generation
you know looking to be a personality
they don't show the cracks and the flaws
and so we we really basically following
a bunch of personalities really people
who don't display their humanity
and we're wondering why we feel
more depressed or more stressed out
because
and this is where it gets in the film
making for myself we're imitating a
false reality
you know and so we we we want to
challenge people to
tell honest stories about vices and
virtues
and only follow those things that are
honest
in their vices and honest in their
virtues so even if you see me do
something virtuous
don't assume inside a hundred percent i
was
clear from not trying to come up right
it's always a wrestle you know so i like
that
you know somebody's too whole you know
it's like we say in the street if
somebody
is is so perfect it's like man i can't
trust you
what's going on here absolutely back
yeah yeah yeah yeah i wanted to kind of
loop back into this this idea to you
know
hey just everything that you've done
around you know with your studying and
reading and teaching on james baldwin
and not not in the um not in a
down plain way but the messiness of
everything that he went through it's not
pain-free i mean with you know all the
challenges that you talked about the
intersection of just the mental health
challenges and the activism and
i just wonder if you could elaborate on
just what you've learned in that journey
he's not even after he's been talking
about this
challenge of wholeness in the cracks and
as we talked about the neuroscience of
importance of
walking through pain what has that
journey been like for you in terms of
understanding from history what others
have had to go through even to try and
affect
change you know when i was working on my
book on bo
uh begin again with baldwin um
you know the sentences initially didn't
dance
and i remember hearing jimmy say
something in my head
you know well if we're gonna do this
together oh boy you're gonna have to
deal with you
and so i had to i had to go back and
deal with the fact that
i'm still you know i still got daddy
issues
that i'm still this this wounded little
boy and once i started grappling with
you know my own relationship with my
father the sentences started jumping
hmm so baldwin says you can't run away
from your fear you got to run towards it
it's a sign of maturity and what he's
saying is that the messiness of american
life
is actually a reflection of the
messiness of our interior lives
so that unexamined life to use socrates
is
uh you know dictum the unexamined life
isn't worth living
right but the unexamined life also
generates a world you know
that puts us all in peril and so part of
what i learned
because jimmy was always on the verge of
disaster
you know he tried to commit suicide
twice
he was drowning himself in alcohol i
barely survived writing the book because
he was demanding so much of me
and it wasn't until i'll say this it
wasn't until i saw
i read it i saw an exchange between him
and nikki giovan oh my goodness
and nikki giovanni a.d and jimmy was
jimmy's baldwin at this point nikki
giovanni is a young sister up-and-coming
poet
and she was like baldwin was talking
about you know black men having
to go to work and come home and she says
lie to me yes and baldwin's confused
she says lie to me you come home and you
take it out on me lie to me
and it was in that moment that exchange
where baldwin's demand for a certain
kind of honesty that was almost tearing
my world apart
right um came into view in a different
sort of way
nikki gave me a license to hold him
at arm's length to a certain degree
but at the end of the day doc
a certain kind of maturity requires
a confrontation with who you
are so that you can actually release
yourself into who you can be
and baldwin would take that formulation
and apply it to the nation
unless you confront who you are for real
you're never going to become anything
otherwise
that's good you know so that's that's
the formulation yeah
yeah no that's so good so many parallels
there and i mean
to be honest that's something i'm
continuing to try just to wrestle with
you know even the parallels not not to
take it too far but
about the state of our country and how
we think about mental health
that aspect of denial that's there and
the challenge of
addressing something when you're in
denial so you know i was mentioning that
whole thing about
avoidance so you know people are going
through anxiety the key is to not avoid
getting into the situation it's just
gonna get bigger and bigger and your
mind's gonna be that much harder
to deal with it the next time and just
all the parallels that that come out
between those two i haven't quite
you know formulated it yet but it's
still and you've been
mentioning that as well just the danger
just the danger that
of living in that that space and i'm
sure maybe we'll come back to that in
terms of the
commentary on the country too but yeah i
want to give you a chance to kind of
respond to what
all this truth that uh eddie's dropping
as well
yeah no i mean that that i can speak
from that first of all that nikki
giovanni james baldwin
interview that is like on the top five
just pieces that you need to consume
it was phenomenal and like he said with
baldwin being baldwin
and she being up and coming but she
challenged him
showed me a lot about who she still
is and who we need to be as people
like don't get caught up in this
personality but
but look at who they are is this right
is this wrong does it need to be
challenged and i think
you know going to his point we
we take on so many i would say lies
and deceptions that we aren't strong
enough to run into the thing we feel
fear most and come out and make it out
on the other end
i can't tell you the number of people
who say
yeah man i i get what you say a.d about
you know facing the fears
and you gotta deal with the trauma but i
don't know if i'm gonna make it on the
other side
and my response is what a low view of
yourself
and what a low view of humanity that you
don't believe you had a strength
to make it through this pain
that isn't supposed to be the marker of
who you are
so so i i'll go if i'm telling you yo
you can actually heal from this yeah but
i'm used to work
working with this this broken arm but
you know it can be
healed and better if if we break any i
get that but i don't know if i'll make
it through the other
side of the other side of the pain
and a lot of times i'm thinking wow what
what has convinced us
of that that's a that's a huge
presupposition
and so i'm always challenging people to
be more inspired be more
uh aspiring of themselves and they
reject these these false narratives that
this this low place or a low station
that we have is where we we're supposed
to just survive
through life you know yeah
you know surviving versus thriving but
it's not easy as you mentioned too and
just and we'll get back to some of the
what you brought in your book too but
just all the traumas
that people go through and just all the
lack of control that comes with that
so in some ways i think sometimes
there's a false sense of safety and not
minimizing it all but a false sense of
safety
and not moving forward because at least
then people feel like they can control
that
aspect versus going through to a place
where they may not have control again
all the challenges that come through
that i mean there's obviously
ways that trauma counselors and folks
can help people through that but i think
that's that's a
key piece as well but i think it's so
important that you bring that
to people and show what is on the other
side because it gets back to that
idea of the pain too and how much
stronger we are when we go through the
pain
i'm going to stay in my lane in the
neuroscience and not try and venture out
but
yeah there is one thing on that say one
thing on that
i i think also i'll speak directly to
uh you know african american descendants
of slaves i will speak
directly to this we downplay the fact
that
we tangibly made it through what i would
call
some of the most hellacious terrorizing
and inhumane tangible things i we we
only have to talk about
the actual morality of it i'm just
talking about
physically and that came to light when i
was able to do this documentary in ghana
and i physically were in these places
where you couldn't see
the light of day for months on end we're
talking about a different level of
solitary confinement
right are you standing there you go
there's there's no way there should be a
physical
person we ain't even got to the boats
we're talking about the processing
castles
right and then you go before the
processing castles the 500 mile journey
and you go we have we my answers did
this too
so when you when you come through all
that you go
i don't know what it is i don't know how
i'm gonna get there
but i've been born to triumph my people
my specific people are born to triumph
it may be jay-z we may not know what the
tools are
but i do know this
i'm born a triumph and that's something
as
i as i look at us as is brown man i'm
like
nah i ain't believing that lie
yeah you know for real for real real
talk
you know real talk anything you want to
follow up
you know i use a statement yeah you know
i used to say to my son i don't
didn't used to say i say it to my son
all the time and i say it to myself the
world conspires to make you small
and the question you have to ask
yourself is will you be complicit
come on
and if you don't if you're not going to
be complicit then you must do like john
coltrane
take giant steps absolutely
you know what i mean so i think and you
know
one way to render a.d's point is that
you know we all are born with crown
above our head
the question is how will you grow into
it
will you grow into it and part of the
challenge we face
over and over again is getting people to
see that
because again the world tries to make us
small
because you got some folks in the most
cosmopolitan city in the world
who can't see beyond their borough their
neighborhood
i'm not talking about folk in the delta
i'm talking about [ __ ] new york yeah
talking about folks in chicago talking
about focus los angeles right so
there's a sense in which to to
understand
one's life as the canvas to create art
to create beauty
right no matter the circumstance is is a
challenge it's hard to do
um so how do we break through that is
the question you know
um but uh i know i don't want to be
complicit
i'm going to i'm going to sound like
melville melville's barter b descriptor
i prefer not to
[Laughter]
so good
that's good i'm still i mean i'm still
harping back to my uh
just the community part and a.d i'm
still feeling that like what what are
the steps what other steps
[Laughter]
i think i mean in some ways it's a um
even the way even the way you describe
that with your son
like and the influence that you
mentioned that each of us have in the
interactions in our spheres of influence
and the impact of having those
conversations and building that
sense of community even one person at a
time i think is so
so powerful um
yeah what else i got no you're good no i
was just thinking about my son right you
know
i remember we were in a um airport when
it came the decision to not charge the
police officers who killed tamir rice
and i immediately looked back to find my
son six two
he was a at the time you know a
d1 prospect for basketball and i'm
looking at him and he's pacing around
the airport like a caged panther
and i'm trying to figure out how do i
keep
this rage from taking root in his spirit
how do i keep you know the anger from
turning on him
right and part of what we
i was trying to do at the time and i
failed miserably on certain levels
was to really to get him to understand
himself
in relation to others right
not to not to let the anger take root in
here
but to really use it as a way to
motivate changing the world as such
and again that that requires this i thou
relationship right that requires to
for him to think of himself in in more
expansive terms in the life
but you know it was a challenge doc it
was a challenge
because you know we both were pacing
like panthers to be honest with you yeah
yeah and i appreciate your honesty too
and
and voicing the challenge and what you
had to help him
walk through i mean i'm thinking of just
so many folks who
you know we've been doing that in so
many different ways and i would say the
one thing that's been really
encouraging this community idea keeps
coming up too but the way that people
were able to not only just internalize
it but to externalize it and to build
community
with that so you know even within
neuroscience by time this airs this will
be a couple weeks out but there's a
black and neural
event that's been going on that started
from one student's tweet
a year ago now they have 20 000
followers on twitter they've done you
know 56 events in the last year
and just the way that they've been able
to galvanize a community
as students as trainees because they
took that pain and tried to build
something with it rather than just
getting
stuck in themselves even though that
would be so easy to do but just
not that it's a solution to everything
but there's been so much that's happened
because of that movement
people who you know all the things that
happen with people being in
predominantly white spaces feeling like
they're the only ones
and people being able to say oh i didn't
know there was this person here there's
this person here and being able to
connect in that way
and just what that has been in terms of
just people's day-to-day
the encouragement they've gotten from
that so i think you know that to me
that's been just a great example of
seeing the young people just rising up
and that's what i'm moving forward
in the midst of the pain that's what's
been spinning
all right here here you go i got you
first step you got to know
history and know your history i think
that's very important even down to the
fact of
i still when i started taking this
journey i started asking my mom
what happened what was happening to you
while you were pregnant with me
a lot of people don't know those things
that and and i've and i uncovered a key
story
because my my life has also been marked
by
everything just felt like a fight though
i grew up in detroit and things were
crazy everything just felt like a fight
like why is everything feel so hard
and she told me a story recently that
shocked my mind she goes
well son i was waiting to tell you this
you know when your mom says okay what's
she about to tell me
she says she she says at the time
medicine wasn't as advanced as it is now
and a dr
turner said to me she says
if your son doesn't figure out how to
come through this canal
because we can't grab him or we'll kill
him if he doesn't figure out how to come
to the
through this canal you both will die
think about that so i go
that makes sense she says so you you you
had to
figure out things with no manual even
before you took your first breath
wow now that explains a lot
so i'm like thank you for the story mom
why you ain't telling me this earlier
but praise god
you know but that
but that that gives context now
to why life has felt like a struggle
though there's been triumphs those are
the stories we need to uncover in our
personalizing our historical eyes
i'll give you another just that helped
me from
ida b wells when i realized
her suffrage not only trying to get
people to understand the tragedy of
lynching
in the white church but then the
pushback she got in the black church
i go oh this helps me understand what
we would be up against even in showing
people the humanity
of truth some people are going yeah we
just want to stay undercover though
don't shine the light on the truth
because it may affect
the thing we're surviving with
right so so those things help so your
history
understand history and then the last
thing i would say that people don't want
to do you got to do it daily
they don't want to name the things that
that pain them
so that could be in in in a daily thing
like hey
hey babe when you said that that hurt
hey son when you treating me like that
in front of other parents that hurt i
remember i had to have a conversation
with my daughter as
i think she was eight years old we were
at a tennis tournament and i didn't
i didn't react but i pulled it to her
side i said babe hey the way
you're treating me it feels like i'm
doing nothing for you as a parent that
hurts
now is that where i come from no
i had to learn that but that helped her
understand that dad is a person
in his emotions and then that helps her
know how to
process and flush out her emotions wow
that's so good
i didn't say i took a lot of bravery on
your part too
and not be the black pair like oh oh so
this is what you got
bring your little come here snatch it
off the court
but there's so much teaching that you
did in that moment too
absolutely for her just to be able to to
show that example
yeah of the importance of naming it yeah
being able to address it head on
so yeah yeah so good
well i'm not leaving much time to talk
about the country but i did want i did
want to pull that in
you know just a little bit in terms of i
mean all the all the things that we've
brought up that i think are so important
um and talking about those aspects of
community and what we do
staying in our lane our interactions
spiritual influence
but when it comes to the country as a
whole
where where are we in this in this state
of
denial versus really trying to move
things forward so i know we don't have
time to get into all the details but
even all the conversations around
critical race theory which of course
it's based more on the law school
setting seems to be getting blown up and
pushed back and all these different
types of things and i've heard you say
that you know some of the pushback has
been an attempt to arrest
what we thought was a genuine racial
reckoning in this country
so i'm just curious to wrap up like what
your just what your thoughts are about
where we are as a country and what we
really need to do
to move this forward as we talk about
the personal community but how do we
change
where we are as a nation well i think
you know we're in
in real time experiencing the
reassertion of the lie
every single time at every single moment
when the nation is on the cusp of
fundamentally grappling with the central
contradiction that threatens democracy
the nation white people in particular
double they double down on the ugliness
and we're seeing it in real time right
now
you know i'm from the coast of
mississippi so i know a little bit about
hurricanes
you know the front end of a hurricane is
very violent
tears up everything but then there's the
eye and then you come
you the eye allows you to come out and
assess the damage
but the tail is coming and the tail is
as bad as the front end
the tail is still coming so we're
we're at a crossroads and i'm not sure
if we double down on the ugliness this
time
whether or not the nation will survive
to be honest with you
wow um and what do you give me i
need some thoughts when you say double
down on the ugliness
the the idea that this must be a white
nation in the vain
so they're going to disenfranchise folk
they're going to
you know the at the moment in which we
were trying to
address policing in the country yeah um
passing just something that was really
baseline the george floyd
justice and policing act they're already
trying to pull back qualified immunity
they're trying to gut it
and at the same time that they're trying
to gut it they're now
trafficking in the language of the
increase in violent crime as a
justification to read
to redouble the efforts that led to the
carceral state in the first place
so we're in the midst of a reassertion
of a way of being um and the people who
are doing it don't give a damn about
democracy so the two of them these
things converging
i don't know if this place will survive
to be honest with you
if they do it i don't know if we will
survive it to be honest with you
so that's good you know what's
interesting you say that because the
friends been on my head to watch
this docu-series called uh how to become
a dictator how to be
how to be a dictator on netflix and
episode one talks exactly
about what you're talking about and why
dictators rise
is because they say what a lot of people
actually
feel and want
and you're seeing it because you know
people are like man
how is this and they go no it's been
there they just needed someone they can
get behind
exactly and that's where we are
so yeah yeah
but you know as baldwin would say human
beings are miracles and disasters at the
same time
we have to protect ourselves from the
disasters that we've become but if we
show up
if we all show up and risk everything
there's a chance for a miracle so
we just need to show up yeah and that's
good i mean i was gonna be my next
question where do we have hope
and the missouri thing yeah you know
baldwin we have potent baldwin again
jimmy has jimmy has this wonderful line
he says he has his wonderful line doc he
says hope
is invented every day and if hope is
invented every day that means you be
beaten back despair every day so
yeah yeah we got hope that we're going
to have hope in us we're not naive it's
a blue
soaked hope guy yeah i'll take it i'll
take it
and to pull in the psychology and
neuroscience again just because that's
who i am
i mean there's so much evidence from
that you know as people if we just talk
about therapy
if you were going through therapy if
they have hope they're that much more
likely to get through
and get to a place of healing maybe not
wholeness or complete healing
but to actually be able to move through
in that place and then from a
neuroscience
perspective just that expectation what
that does to our brains and the way our
brains process different situations
so i think that hope is key in a lot of
ways yeah and there's there's so much
evidence for that so it's something that
we got to hold on to
maybe i need to start pulling in baldwin
in some of my neuroscience courses too
tie those two together what are you
thinking a.d
what do you think yeah you know i'm
i'm always gonna default to
[Music]
uh hope that's tangible and a hope
that's honest
and i think in order for us to survive
we have to have an
honest hope and i
i would agree with eddie that the lie is
resurfacing
and sometimes you have the lie of a
false hope
and that's what becomes dangerous you
know now
now i'ma say this as the person of color
and you know on the heels of reading uh
cast the book i actually think
people who know true oppression
know what true hope is and in those
darkest moments you'll see
those people being the ones that are
leaned upon because we actually know our
way through the darkness
right so that's that's the when i have
hope i go
man we were born for something we were
born for dark days
and when those dark days come they're
gonna come i hope we are united enough
as people
to lead the the right way
some fresh word well said i'm all said
well i appreciate both of you being on
here and so much truth and so much
richness in this conversation uh we
covered a lot of ground in that short
period of time and
i'm grateful to both of you i know this
will be a blessing to listeners as well
and
encourage people to continue wrestling
with these topics
as we all seek to move forward into a
better place
thanks again to both of you for jumping
on the addi hour definitely appreciate
it appreciate your time
appreciate you that yeah likewise
appreciate it
you